it turns out that becoming an instant
icon isn't always the greatest thing for
a child psyche Emma Watson who was cast
as Hermione Granger in the Harry Potter
film series at the tender age of nine
recently opened up to British Vogue
about a years-long struggle with guilt
over having landed the plum role what
some was famously picked from a crowd of
would-be Hermione's during open
auditions at her school and as soon as
poss a fans were introduced to her in
2001 s Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone or philosopher's stone in the UK
they knew that the role had been
perfectly cursed her droll delivery and
adult mannerisms are suited Hermione
perfectly and as a series cast grew into
young adults over the course of eight
films it became clear that Watson's
formidable talent was growing as well
boys I think it's time we teach weasal
be respected I hope you sell but
immediate worldwide fame can obviously
be tough for any kid to handle and what
some was no difference in her
conversation with folk the actress said
that she experienced a great deal of
guilt over feeling burdened by said Fame
when the role could have gone to any
number of young actresses perhaps Warner
would have handled the exposure better
the star said I've sat in therapy and
felt really guilty about to be honest
like why why me why somebody else would
have enjoyed and wanted this aspect of
it more than I did
the actress went on to say this as a
child it was truly impossible to know
what she was signing up for when
producers picked her to play Hermione I
was nine years old and I got literally
picked out of a lineup in my school gym
that wasn't even an acting school a star
related how as part of mania swept the
globe she had to make a conscious effort
to reorient herself mentally in the face
of massive worldwide fame Watson
explained and part of I think my sense
of peace within myself has been him
remembering my identity I belong to
family I come from a place I have roots
there's a whole pretty big existence my
identity that I have what sense is a
struggle that has been faced by child
actors for generations but even among
their ranks a few have experienced being
part of a global phenomenon like Harry
Potter adapted from the wildly popular
young adult novels by JK Rowling the
eight films on the main series combined
to grossed nearly 8 billion
dollars are the worldwide box office
when the fantastic Beast spin-off films
in which Watson did not appear are
factored in Harry Potter is a third
highest-grossing film franchise in
history behind only the juggernaut star
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and Star
Wars on top of that the main parts are
cast literally grew up in front of the
camera playing the same characters a
situation even fewer child actors have
had to contend with it was a prolonged
and intense level of attention that
would have been enough to make just
about any ordinary kid flameouts
but thankfully watson and a co-star
Daniel Radcliffe and Rupert grints
managed to come away from the experience
as well-adjusted successful adults
Watson in particular has continued
working steadily since the Maine Potter
series ended appearing in such films as
The Bling Ring and Noah before scoring
another mega hit with Disney's 2017
live-action adaptation of Beauty and the
Beast which took home well over a
billion dollars globally this Christmas
Day she can be seen in the latest
adaptation of Louisa May Alcott's
classic novel Nestle women despite stiff
competition from the likes of Jumanji
the next level and Star Wars Episode
nine the rise of Skywalker the flick is
expected to do respectable box office
thanks to its blinding star power and
the shore guiding hand of writer
director Greta Gerwig the creative mind
behind 27 teams widely acclaimed
coming-of-age drama D Lady Bird of
course Watson's present success largely
came at the cost of anything resembling
a normal childhood but the actress
seemed to have come to terms with her
experience and the struggles that came
with it even if she had never made
another film after the Harry Potter
series
she would have been fondly remembered by
fans around the world what's a boatload
of talent and shows that she'll be
gracing the silver screen for years to
come some things she no longer feels
quite so bad about it took me a long
time but I'm very happy check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]